انتقد الرئيس البرازيلي جيادا بولسونارو الرئيس المنتخب جو بايدن خلال خطاب متلفز على المستوى الوطني حيث مازحًا حول اللجوء إلى البارود إذا لم تكن الدبلوماسية مع الولايات المتحدة كافية بولسونارو حليف دونالد ترامب وواحد من عدد قليل من القادة العالميين الذين لديهم التزم الصمت بشأن فوز بايدن في خطاب ألقاه ليلة الثلاثاء حيث أشار إلى أن مرشحًا رئاسيًا معينًا قد تحدث عن العواقب الاقتصادية إذا لم يتم السيطرة على الحرائق في الأمازون البرازيلية دون ذكر بايدن بالاسم الذي قال إن الدبلوماسية قد لا تكون كافية للتعامل معها التهديد والمزاح بأنه يجب عليك اقتباس البارود في نفس الخطاب ، كما أدلى بولسونارو بتعليقات مثيرة للجدل حول جائحة covet 19 الذي قال إنه عندما يتعلق الأمر بفيروس كورونا ، تحتاج البرازيل إلى التوقف عن كونها بلدًا من المخنثين ، لكنه استخدم إهانة معادية للمثليين اشتكى منها أن كل شيء الآن يتعلق بالوباء ، قال إنه يأسف للضحايا الذين ماتوا لكنه أضاف أننا سنموت جميعًا واحدًا  اليوم ،
انخفض عدد الحالات اليومية في البرازيل
في الشهرين الماضيين ،
لكن لا يزال لديها ثاني أكبر
عدد من الوفيات في جميع أنحاء العالم
أكثر من 162
ألفًا ولديها ثالث أكبر عدد من الحالات
5.7 مليون
شاستا دارلينجتون سي إن ساو باولو